hello Internet
hiya how's it going you asking me only
instead I don't care about you so much I
assume they're fine because they're
watching a slow my last video on the
Internet well today we've got a car
airbag and we I was always amazed that
when an air bag goes off in a car in the
steering wheel I thought how does the
airbag not hit the driver in the fear I
want it like how does there just deploy
this face and it turns out airbags
deploy so immensely fast that usually
they're fully out and inflated before
the driver has even moved from the
impact so let's see how fast that really
is my filming it two-and-a-half thousand
frames a second it a fee with a pad and
flex got batteries here gonna connect
them up and hopefully that'll work but
I'm this scared about this one good all
right Dan we're this for safety Donna
this good all right good friend huh
different
hey those fast good watch the egg do you
see we jump No
Oh whoa that's fast that's so fast
you're flapping about straight in your
face now you notice the airbags never
just explode because they're actually
vented at the back this in the explosion
just puts air into a bag that is not
even sealed so the air can leak out
without the bag just exploding from the
pressure did not know that pretty cool
in it yeah what's so very hot yeah I
felt that afterwards I've touched it it
was actually really warm
all right there the second air bag yep
that first one went off so you can't
really see any sort of scale of speed so
we're gonna try and drop something next
to this one right yeah so time it right
so we drop something as this one goes
off see you're using a standard
procedure kitchen knife this wouldn't be
slower guys if we didn't have the
completely incorrect equipment to lose
them ready yeah yeah whoo where'd it go
me over there tree jeez that's crime
holy crap Oh God
good more literally that all happened so
quickly I blinked the airbag was over
there and the glasses are confused as to
where we hear their ads as limo guys use
that look what happened this was much
bigger than the other I had a lot more
volume to it in there it was like a I
guess you're further away it looks
awesome but it's the same fabric yellow
so yeah that shot off here and as I drop
the water bottle the water glass of
water hit the table and shut off look
how far it went really quickly as well
I'm bearing in mind it didn't get shot
up in the air just got shot along with
floor and just like hit them lost about
25 minutes me what's that me Oh Tiffany
that is amazing we're miles away and the
glass survived yeah available in the
recipe store well I hope you enjoyed
that video please follow us on Twitter
do all those things
yeah and be careful with your kashikar
and I dispose of the airbag now get the
boys yeah this video was sponsored by
audible.com they have over 150,000
audiobooks go to audible.com for slash
slo-mo for a free book I recommend
Philip Pullman's the amber spyglass is
from His Dark Materials trilogy it's
really good book about this thick so I'm
probably not to read it so if you go to
audible.com you can listen to it much
easier
you